a beautiful black woman like that just
trying to have a nice night out with
Usher come on KiKi can do no wrong
Winnie Harlow Loki was disrespectful
when she curb Usher the next day oh I
was disrespectful he curb Usher like
that
kicked him to the curb yeah
sure like that
but for real what would you want your
girl to do in that situation get sung
too
yeah you would want her to get sung too
absolutely nah we out I want to get
something too by Usher say what I want
to get sung too by Usher really what
song would you like anyone which one he
got hits all of them what's your
favorite one there goes my baby
[Laughter]
we need to go
and he's so incredible and he's so
talented so he deserves all the
attention he deserves the flowers I'm
glad the younger generation is fine
about Usher yes that's another reason I
always care about my girlfriend about
you because he's too old for it he don't
know that's the other thing like that
there was that girl what's up what's the
girl sweetie sweetie was getting sunk to
by Usher and she wasn't reacting to it
because she don't know no words the song
she didn't go through this she doesn't
know Usher
o-n-d and every time
[Laughter]
I was like my body
I was like a submarine bro implosion
[Applause]
[Music]
don't keep me waiting I got plans
nice and quiet
[Music]
[Applause]
don't let
go
pull it up
don't keep me waiting
we skip one we just we kind of just
repeat yes all I'm saying is Usher gonna
have your girl Drip Drop drip naked
getting Buffet
so be careful
[Music]
we gotta go yeah let's go gotta get
something too let's bring our girls
we fired man come on what date nights
I'll be jealous I've been kicking her
out of here I can't believe you I want
your girls to be surf instructors losing
ass
y'all are crazy for that bro y'all are
really crazy
come on bro you want your girl's job in
a bikini you were a surf instructor bro
I'm a man
it's different what if I built
what if that girl's grows up when you
say yo you can't be wearing that around
me you got a man she dating Jonah so
useless we're still filming you peoples
we still feeling you peoples put a
shirt on yo
put a shirt on put some pants on
put some jeans
put your jeans
on tired of this he was a surf
instructor in fire
[Laughter]
did it leak
violently oh my goodness yeah are you
ever gonna go to like like a like a
durable country like Africa or some
like Safari Africa is not a country
[Laughter]
stop behaving how you dress like 10
seconds
country like Africa like Safari neither
of which our country
what a dumb guys
a country no it's a terrible rapper
come on I got plans to put my hands in
places
[Music]
uh since we've been waiting for this
tell me do you wanna get
freaky
I you like a surface
those are the lyrics
surfing is crazy
you guys yeah
I realize how crazy that song just gets
out of nowhere
[Laughter]
he's up there